Gas! It's all around you.
It's in space. It's on Mars.
It's dissolved in your blood, and in your
soda.
It's everywhere.
And it's easy to forget that we're submerged in an ocean of gas, but it's there all the time.
You can feel it if you wave your arms around.
Can't look cool while you're feeling it but
you can feel it. It's there.
Those little molecules and atoms bumping around
against your hands as you wave them around.
Feel it? Are you doing this?
I've got good news and bad news about gases.
First the good news, when they're behaving
themselves
it is extremely easy to describe their behavior
theoretically, experimentally and mathematically.
The bad news is, they almost never behave
themselves.
[Theme Music]
The first mathematical description of a behavior
of a gas was a link between pressure and volume.
In a closed system like the inside of this
balloon,
when we decrease the volume of the balloon
the pressure inside goes up.
And if we could somehow expand the balloon,
then the pressure inside the balloon would go down.
If I keep pushing on it the pressure inside
might go so high that it'll break.
I hope...I can't do it.
It's a very strong balloon!
The relationship here is a simple one.
When you multiply the pressure and volume
together, you get a constant.
As long as the temperature and amount of gas
stays the same, so does that constant.
It's called Boyle's Law, and it was a pretty
big deal back in the 1600s.
It's also, one of the greatest scientific
mis-attributions of all time.
Robert Boyle was a super rich Englishman,
raised in Ireland.
His father was so rich that he paid another
family to raise his children.
I guess because he was too busy administering
lands or something.
Boyle had lots of great ideas about science
and chemistry.
His most important one, and this is arguably
even more important than Boyle's Law,
being that chemists should publish papers
not on what they feel is correct,
but rather on theories that have been backed
up by experimentation.
Richard Towneley a wealthy, but considerably less wealthy, Englishman struck up a relationship with Boyle.
Telling him about some of his work that would disprove one of those "But it feels right" kind of chemists.
Boyle published the paper mentioning that
work, which he called Towneley's Hypothesis.
But which ended up, because of Boyle's superior scientific standing and possibly his wealth, being called Boyle's Law.
But here's the really messed up thing:
the experiments that led to the creation of
this theory were actually done largely by
Towneley's family friend and physician, Henry Power, who's not a member of the aristocracy at all.
He was just a working class scientist.
Power was working on a publication that would
have snared him the position as discover of
the relationship between the pressure and
volume of a gas.
But Boyle, having discussed the ideas with
Towneley privately, published his first,
attributing Towneley as the sole researcher, ensuring that Power's contributions were all but lost to history.
Henry Power's Wikipedia page didn't even mention
Boyle's Law until a few weeks ago,
when I personally added a paragraph about
it, with proper citations of course.
But no matter who thought it up or who it
got named after, Boyle's Law is pretty cool.
For a given amount of gas at a constant temperature, pressure times volume always equals the same number.
But where is that constant coming from,
and why is it different for different amounts
of gas at different temperatures?
Well it was more than a hundred years before
we'd figure out the answer to those questions,
with the help of a Frenchman Jacques Charles and our old, Italian house-elf friend Amedeo Avogadro.
Charles and Avogadro created equations much
like Boyle's law
with two features of a gas being linked directly
together by constants.
Charles discovered that volume divided by
temperature equals a constant,
as long as the pressure remains the same.
And then Avogadro figured out that volume
divided by the number of moles in the container
at a constant pressure and temperature gave
yet another constant.
But here's the crazy cool thing:
all of these scientists were basically dealing
with a different form of the same equation.
An equation that we must never forget, and is gonna be stuck in my head until I die, and here's how it works:
Pressure times volume is equal to the number of moles of substances times a constant times temperature.
P V equals n R T: The Ideal Gas Law, which works for all gases as long as they behave themselves.
Now here's the cool part,
using this equation we can show how all of these chemists were dealing with the same relationship.
They were just clumping various variables
together in different orders.
All of the chemists we just mentioned: Charles, Avogadro and Boyle (or more properly Towneley and Power),
figured out their contribution to the Ideal
Gas Law experimentally.
But more interesting to me, is that it can
be understood theoretically.
First, we have to understand what each of
these variables actually mean.
In that same way the atoms and molecules that
make up gases
are bouncing against things, applying pressure
to them.
This balloon is inflated because the molecules
are bouncing around inside of it,
bumping into the inside of the balloon harder than the molecules bouncing off the outside of the balloon.
Scientists generally measure pressure with
the S.I. unit of force:
Newtons per area, meters squared, which is
shortened to pascals.
But since pascals are so tiny we either use
kilopascals
or we use the pressure here on earth at sea
level, that we call one atmosphere or one atm.
Completely by chance, one atmosphere is equal
to 101325 pascals,
but that's so close that we often just say that one atmosphere is 100,000 pascals or 100 kilopascals.
Volume is the amount of space particles have
to exist inside of.
So yeah, that makes sense, when the volume
goes down, the pressure goes up,
because there are more particles in a smaller
space, and they'll each hit the walls more often.
N is simply the amount of gas, the number
of moles in the system.
Here I am decreasing the amount of gas in the system and in response the volume is decreasing. Obviously.
But so is the pressure inside the balloon.
R in the Ideal Gas Law is called the Universal
Gas Constant.
Even though, as we will see in a coming episode,
it is neither universal or constant.
It's 8.3145 liters kilopascal per kelvin mole.
Temperature, is experienced by you and me as hot or cold but at the atomic level it's kinetic energy.
Literally, how fast or slow the average particle
is moving.
So if temperature goes up, so will the pressure
as the particles are moving faster
and thus will run into the sides of the container
more often.
So now we know about all of the little bits of the Ideal Gas Law, so let's take a look at it in action.
We here at Crash Course generally like to be very safe. This is a little bit of overkill here.
I put a little bit of water into this soda
can and now I'm boiling it.
So instead of atmosphere gas in this can right
now there's water vapor,
and it's hot and all the molecules are zipping
around like crazy.
We pick it up and we plop it down inside of
that -- ooh! -- and it crushes itself.
So what just happened there?
Well, let's see what the gas law can tell
us.
So which of these things are changing?
Starting on the right hand side: R, is constant,
so that can't change.
The temperature of the gas though, that definitely
changed;
it drops like mad when it's exposed to the
ice water.
N is decreasing too as water vapor is condensing into liquid water, it thus disappears from the gas phase.
So the next result on the right hand side
is a decrease,
and that means that the left hand side has
to have a decrease too.
So on to the left hand side.
The pressure does indeed drop because the lower temperature makes the molecules move more slowly,
thus bumping into the sides of the can a lot
less than before.
And volume drops too, but not quite for the
reason you might think.
It's really that the pressure inside the can
goes so low, that the pressure outside the can,
the atmospheric pressure, literally crushes
the can.
Now I understand that you probably don't think
this is as cool as I do,
but understanding the physical reality of
atoms and molecules smacking into things is
a special kind of beautiful for me.
It's also pretty cool that if you know any 3 things about a gas, you can figure out the fourth using the ideal gas law.
Of course, not all gases behave ideally,
and all gases deviate from the law at low
temperatures or high pressures.
But we'll save that discussion for a later
episode.
Jargon fun time.
STP means standard temperature and pressure,
which according to the lords of chemistry is 0 degrees Celsius and 100,000 pascals or 100 kilopascals.
One mole of any ideal gas takes up 22.4 liters of space at STP, which is a fact that can simplify a lot of calculations.
Absolute zero is the temperature at which
all movement of all particles stops.
It is zero kelvins or -273.15 degrees Celsius.
And that's all for this episode. Thank you
for watching Crash Course Chemistry.
If you were paying attention you learned about
how the work of some amazing thinkers combined
to produce the Ideal Gas Law;
how none of those people were Robert Boyle,
and how the Ideal Gas Equation allows you to find out pressure, volume, temperature or number of moles,
as long as you know three of those four things.
And you learned a few jargon-y phrases to help you sound like you know what you're talking about.
This episode of Crash Course Chemistry was
written by me.
The script was edited by Blake de Pastino
and our chemistry consultants were Dr. Heiko
Langner and Edi Gonzalez.
It was filmed, edited and directed by Nicholas
Jenkins.
Our script supervisor was Caitlin Hofmeister
and our sound designer is Michael Aranda.
Our graphics team is Thought Cafe.